[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I first heard about the
Shalva band back in November
when they came to my
community for a concert,
and I was amazed by
their musical talent,
I was inspired by
their personal stories.
I went to the show expecting
to see an amateur performance
and instead I was very moved
to hear a talented band
with a very professional
presentation.
And that was an experience
that really changed the way
that I thought
about and understand
inclusion and accessibility.
That's really all
the introduction
that this band needs.
Its certainly all
the introduction
that I'm going to give.
I'm going to ask
that everyone please
shut off your cell phones,
put them on silent,
close your laptops.
I want to introduce
Kalman Samuels who's
the founder of Shalvo, who's
going to give us a minute
or two of background
on the organization.
And then we'll
hear from the band.
Kalman?
[APPLAUSE]
KALMAN SAMUELS: Good afternoon.
It is a total privilege
to be here at Google,
and I want to think
David and everybody
who has made this possible.
Just to give you Shalva
101 for two minutes.
I'm a Canadian from
Vancouver, Canada.
Went to Israel when I was
18 on my way to France.
Stayed, became religious,
and my beautiful wife, Malki,
and our second child, Yossi,
at the age of 11 months
had a medical issue that
developed and-- well not--
let's say that again.
There was a medical
procedure that went bad,
and he became blind and deaf.
And people asked my wife to
think about putting him out
of the house because he
was very, very challenging.
And my wife would
cry at night and say,
God I am never putting
Yossi out of the house.
But if you ever decide
to help our Yossi,
I'm going to dedicate my
life to helping other mothers
with their challenges.
At the age of eight,
unexpected, Yossi
had a breakthrough to
communication via a teacher
in the deaf school who was
deaf herself, and spelling
the word of palm of his
hand over and over again,
the five Hebrew letters
for the word table
or [SPEAKING HEBREW].
Yossi suddenly lit up, and
she, in her words, said,
he just had his
Helen Keller moment.
So she turned to me.
She said, it's payback time.
I know exactly
what I want to do.
I know how you want
to help other mothers.
It took me three
years to find anyone
who would buy into her dream.
We opened with five children
with cognitive disabilities.
Malki did everything
except for a professional
and a few volunteers.
And it grew in ways that we
could never have foreseen.
Today, we serve over 2000
people a week from birth,
including mothers
who just gave birth
to babies they
weren't expecting,
and all the way through
to independent living
in the community and seniors.
The band is yet
another dream that we
began 11 years ago
and no one could have
expected where they have come.
These are young adults.
These people have the
respect of now making
a living through their music.
And for them to be
playing here at Google
is, in my mind, the ultimate
statement about inclusion,
about integration,
and that, I believe,
is the measure of any program--
whether or not we can
get them into a situation
where they can fulfill their
dreams in such a manner.
So without any further ado,
I'd like to introduce the band.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNOUNCER: Ladies and
gentlemen, coming all the way
from Jerusalem, The Shalva Band.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNOUNCER: Everyone
put your heads together
for The Shalva Band!
[APPLAUSE]
DINA SAMTEH: Hi, everyone.
We are The Shalva Band.
We are very excited
to be here with you.
It's an honor for us to be here.
We are going to sing "One Day."
Ready?
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND, "ONE
DAY"]
DINA SAMTEH: We all have
our difficult moments.
We all have complaints.
But it is important to
understand that there
is much to be thankful for.
Stand up.
I cannot see you, but I hear.
Some of you are still
sitting, am I right?
Please, everyone, stand
up together with me.
For a single moment,
without any reason,
I hope you feel and
understand that there
is a lot to be grateful for.
Thank you for [INAUDIBLE]
in the morning.
Thank you for healthy legs
to go for beautiful walks.
Thank you for laughter.
Thank you for the
ability to see.
Thank you, Father and
Mother, for a good meal.
Thank you for a surprise gift.
Thank you for the opportunity
to sing and create joy.
Thank you for the hard
times, because [INAUDIBLE]..
Thank you for the
privilege of standing
here, being able
to say thank you.
Thank you for support.
Thank you for love.
Thank you for the children.
Thank you for friends.
Thank you for [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you for the hard times
because the only difficult
moment I am able to
appreciate all that I have.
Thank you, God, for
the butterflies.
And thank you, my dear friends.
Please sit down.
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND,
"HALLELUJAH"]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND]
Thank you.
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND,
"SOMEWHERE OVER THE RAINBOW"]
[APPLAUSE]
[JAZZ MUSIC]
GUY MAMAN: Good
evening, everyone.
We are The Shalva Band.
I'd like to introduce
to you the members
of our band, my friends.
We're going to start
with the singers
and end up with me, because
we keep the best to the end.
The first [INAUDIBLE]
singer, Dina Samteh.
[VOCALIZING]
Anael Khalifa.
Naftali Weiss.
[VOCALIZING]
On the drums, we
have Ovadia Yosef.
But I've got to
tell you something.
Ovadia isn't that
too much into jazz.
So, Ovadia, why don't we
take it somewhere else?
YOSEF OVADIA: One,
two, three, four!
[UPTEMPO JAZZ]
Percussion, Tal Kima.
Yair Pomburg.
On the violin, [INAUDIBLE].
On the flute, [INAUDIBLE].
On the guitar, Sarah Samuels.
Put you hands together for
our musical director, Shai Ben
Shushan.
[APPLAUSE]
On the keyboards, Guy Maman.
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND, "HERE
COMES THE SUN"]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID: Wow.
We're going to take
about 10 or 15 minutes
and just get to know our
band members a little bit,
and then we're going to go
back for some more music.
I'm going to start
with an Anael.
ANAEL KHALIFA: Hi.
DAVID: Anael, can you
tell us a little bit more
about what music
means to you, and how
music has changed your life?
ANAEL KHALIFA:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Music for me
is the way to see the world.
It brings all
colors to my world.
Music is very meaningful
to me, every note.
Since I was born, my
parents played music to me.
I didn't have a story
before bed time.
It was CDs.
Music helped me
through childhood.
When I came to
Israel from France
I wanted a lot of attention,
so I started singing,
and people started looking
at me with a different look.
When I joined the
band, I understood
what confidence is, because
this band gave me my confidence.
The fact that I'm here and
performing and singing,
it's not to be
taken for granted.
And that's what music gave me.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID: So you're all
professional musicians,
but I understand that you
all have other jobs and roles
that Shalva, and I'd like
to hear more about some
of the other work that you do.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Hello.
I used to work at the
Shalva coffee shop.
We have a cafe at Shalva.
And now I have a new job.
I wrap teabags at our workshop.
David, the guy who works
with him, brings the tea.
We prepare it.
We put it in tea bags, and
then we wrap it in box,
and we sell them in
the Shalva gift shop.
As you see, I work
with the band as well.
I've performed all
over the world--
London, Mexico, and now I'm
here in New York at Google,
and it's a lot of fun for me.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID: Shai, can you
tell us a little bit
about where and how the
band has been a bridge
across different cultures?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SHAI BEN SHUSHAN: First
of all, hello, everybody.
Thank you, David, that
you bring us to here.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Special
thing about this band
is that it shows the world
that everything is possible.
To see them at first,
when people didn't really
pay attention to
them, and now they're
performing everywhere, every
day, in front of all people.
It's one of the things
that excites me most,
to see that people don't
look at their disabilities,
but at their talent,
their abilities,
and their professionalism.
SHAI BEN SHUSHAN:
Thank you very much.
DAVID: There is no center
like Shalva in the world.
It's the largest
center of its kind.
And, Dina, I'd like to
hear a little bit more
about what you
love about Shalva.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: The truth is that
I love many things at Shalva.
Shalva first of all is a family.
When you hear Shalva you
think it's an organization,
but when you walk in you
feel it's something else.
I came 5 and 1/2
years ago to Shalva.
to volunteer with
kids with disabilities
and help them through music.
And through Shalva, I
am fulfilling my dream.
It built my confidence.
Being with my friends and
with the band director,
Shai, that love me and
support me and strengthen me,
give me strength.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID: I don't want to take
much time away from the music.
Googlers, if you are
interested in more stories,
you certainly can stay after
the show for a few minutes
while the band
will still be here.
I hope that you're finding
this as a great opportunity
to experience inclusion
and accessibility
in a positive and inspiring
way, to think differently
about challenges, achievement,
bravery and acceptance,
and to appreciate the greatness
that can become possible
through motivation
and hard work.
This is a world where people
are people first and foremost.
We are united by our humanity
rather than separated
by our differences, and
The Shalva Band very much
encompasses that
aspect of our culture.
If you have
additional questions,
feel free to linger afterwards.
Otherwise, we'll go
back to the music.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND, "HOTEL
CALIFORNIA"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND,
"TITANIUM"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND]
ANAEL KHALIFA: OK, now we
want to sing the last song.
Are you ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANAEL KHALIFA: OK.
[MUSIC - THE SHALVA BAND, "THE
SOUND OF SILENCE"]
[APPLAUSE]
DINA SAMTEH: Thank you so much.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Encore!
Bravo!
Encore!